[Music]
in sri lanka a tropical island nation
just a few miles southeast of india
children never get a snow day
neither do they have to contend with
earthquakes volcanoes or sandstorms
but three million of its students now
face a different kind of disaster
their schools can't afford ink or even
paper on which to print it
on march 19th the education department
of its largest province announced the
cancellation of all exams for grades 9
10 and 11 for that exact reason
today however paper is the least of its
concerns as entire cities grind as we
speak to a dangerous and unprecedented
halt
prices for essential goods everything
from rice to fuel to medicine have
doubled then tripled and continued
rising
that combined with power outages lasting
up to 15 hours a day have christian nuns
hindus muslims and buddhist monks who
just 10 years ago fought each other in a
civil war all joining hands on the
streets in protest
unfortunately the worst is likely yet to
come
as the last remaining supplies dwindle
away the current nine hours of
electricity and severely overpriced
groceries may soon be remembered as the
good days
and yet sri lanka experts warn is just
the tip of the iceberg
though unique as a country the roots of
many of its current problems are far too
common
the united nations warned last month of
a perfect storm brewing in the
developing world
one expected to leave quote deep and
long-lasting scars
sri lanka in other words may simply be
the first domino to fall this year
and understanding how it got here unable
to afford even paper may offer a preview
of what comes next
[Music]
sponsored by storyblocks where you can
find over a million high quality videos
for your creative projects business or
like us youtube channel
this is an imaginary country
if it imports more things than it
exports we say it has a trade deficit
conversely if it exports more than it
imports it has a trade surplus
now because our frame of reference is
personal finance in which you're told to
spend less than you save or corporations
where profit sounds a lot like a surplus
of money it's tempting to see deficits
as a bad thing
of course as you may already know it's
much more complicated
the united states for instance has a
huge deficit
the slower growing japanese economy
meanwhile has a giant surplus
but what's all too easy to forget is
that the us and to a lesser extent japan
are weird countries
china may win the trade war with the u.s
for example but what does it do with all
that money
invest in the united states
but remember this is a very unique set
of circumstances
it's what economists mean when they say
the us has a privileged position
when china sells things to america it
wants to buy with that money u.s dollars
not somali shillings or iraqi dinars
or sri lankan rupees
to see why this is an issue for a
country like sri lanka stop thinking in
terms of imports versus exports and for
the sake of simplicity think instead
about the actual physical supply of
dollars
when it buys say milk from next door
india it generally pays for those goods
with the us dollars because that's what
india wants
likewise when sri lanka sells its tea to
the uk the british pay it in dollars
you should start noticing two potential
problems here
first if a country imports more than it
exports you can see how it could just
run out of usd it would be effectively
spending more than it's saving
and second running out of usd is
problematic because it's what you need
to buy imports
in other words for countries not named
the united states of america this
balance of payments really is important
here where a negative value equals a
trade deficit you can see that sri lanka
has been in the red so to speak for
quite some time
it imports a huge amount of rice wheat
sugar and medicine not to mention all
its oil
now all this might sound like trade
deficits are some horrible no-good very
bad thing
but as you can see here most countries
run deficits
there's nothing rare or necessarily
catastrophic about having a negative
balance of trade on its own
what all these countries do to make up
the difference is simply borrow
if that sounds unsustainable
well yes and no
in the case of sri lanka its government
has a long history of gross
mismanagement
just last year for example the
government banned the import of all
chemical fertilizers in a bid to become
the world's first all-organic nation
to the surprise of no one but the
president crop yields were immediately
cut in half
you could make a pretty good case that
sri lanka was destined for a crisis of
some kind and that it was only a matter
of when
yet just a few short years ago the
country showed a real economic promise
it had other ways of getting its hands
on dollars
in 2019 tourism accounted for 22 percent
of its total gdp
lonely planet ranked the country the
number one best place to visit that same
year
there are beautiful beaches
wild leopards yoga retreats and stunning
natural landscapes
another source of foreign exchange was
remittances
workers would go overseas earn foreign
currency and send it to their families
back home
but you can probably guess what happened
in 2020
tourism effectively fell to zero
overnight
actually the decline in tourists began
even before the pandemic
in the spring of 2019 terrorists bombed
a string of churches and hotels across
the capital colombo
the tragic and shocking death of 269
people at least 45 of which were foreign
nationals led to a 70 drop in tourist
arrivals
its 7.9 billion dollars of foreign
reserves in 2019 fell to just 1.6
billion by 2021
and if that sounds bad there's an extra
reason on top of the normal badness that
makes it even worse
you may have heard that some countries
intentionally under or overvalue their
currencies
sri lanka is one of those places
let's say a bag of rice from india costs
one usd to import and one usd is
currently worth 200 sri lankan rupees
if sri lanka can convince everyone that
no actually 150 rupees is the value of a
us dollar well now that rice is
effectively 25 percent cheaper
the central bank in other words
overvalued the rupee because the country
depends so heavily on imports
by keeping staple goods affordable
authorities and developing nations
maintain economic and therefore
political stability
if you're wondering why all countries
don't do this the answer is what sri
lanka is going through now
actually maintaining that artificial
exchange rate involves buying and
selling or borrowing foreign currency
which remember sri lanka is running out
of
here you can see where the central bank
kept the rupee at roughly the same value
until it suddenly couldn't when its real
market value took over
the government meanwhile was still
pretending that one usd was worth for
example 150 rupees when everyone else
had decided it was worth 200.
here's what that means in practice
walk into a bank hand them one usd and
they'll give you back 150 rupees walk on
the other hand into a private shop hand
them that same dollar bill and they'll
give you say 200.
it doesn't take long before ward gets
out don't deposit your foreign currency
in the bank it's a scam migrant workers
quickly learn not to send their
remittances home through official
channels
because of this the central bank has
even less foreign currency making it
even harder to maintain its fake
exchange rate
and this is when things get really ugly
really fast
what sri lanka is experiencing now are
the effects of three interconnected
problems
first because the country is running out
of dollars it can't buy enough imports
to keep up with demand meaning there
just isn't enough rice paper or fuel to
go around
second at the same time people's savings
are suddenly worth far less today than
they were yesterday
years of hard work gone overnight
and third not only is the rupee rapidly
depreciating in value but no one knows
where exactly the bottom is
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
see the trend
last week i could afford a dozen bananas
today half as many
every rational household starts stocking
up on essential goods leading to chaos
confusion and chronic under-supply
lines at gas stations were so long that
two men collapsed and died waiting
needless to say the pandemic plus poor
governance had placed the country on
tenuous ground already
then the war in ukraine began
the conflict and the subsequent
sanctions are currently causing the
largest commodity shock in half a
century
here you can see for instance the price
and just as importantly its volatility
of wheat and maize which russia and
ukraine produce 28 and 15 percent of the
global supply of respectively
ukrainian exports alone previously fed
400 million people
some countries get nearly all their
wheat from one or both
these are just the places which source
at least 80 percent of their wheat from
russia and ukraine
on top of this russia also supplies 15
of the world's fertilizer and just as
importantly the fuel used to make
fertilizer
if you drive a car and live on planet
earth you probably don't need to be told
that oil prices are off the charts
many countries have or will react by
banning food exports further
exacerbating the situation for net
importers like sri lanka
now like trade deficits developing
countries being unable to pay back their
loans is not all that uncommon
there's a system for this sort of thing
the equivalent of bankruptcy for nations
normally organizations like the imf and
world bank step in sri lanka last
received a bailout from the imf for 1.6
billion dollars in 2016.
but this time is different
bailouts you see are conditional on
things like having a functional
government and implementing economic
policies which are often unpopular
the imf doesn't just write checks on a
whim
it wants to know that the country won't
end up in the same situation six months
later
these are conditions sri lanka simply
can't meet
while citizens are very justifiably
angry at their government the
unfortunate truth is that political
turmoil and social unrest will likely
only discourage foreign assistance
protesters are right that the country's
economic woes didn't come from nowhere
the groundwork for the current crisis
can be traced back decades when sri
lanka began paying off old loans with
new ones in what the world bank has
compared to a pyramid scheme
while it's easy to connect the dots
between an unprecedented global pandemic
and a sudden economic collapse so too is
it easy to blame chinese loans but
neither theory captures the whole truth
only about 10 percent of sri lanka's
debt is owned by china and its leaders
have been pursuing disastrous policies
for years before any of the recent
events
in 2019 it cut taxes precisely when it
needed public revenue the most
poor governance is not the only but it
is an important ingredient to the
cocktail of calamities it's dealing with
now
what's surprising is not sri lanka's
poor leadership but how quickly it all
unraveled
in a matter of weeks millions of sri
lankans went from living a fairly
middle-class lifestyle cars college
education and leisure to wondering
whether they can eat dinner
this is how countries spiral out of
control
a shock or in this case a trifecta of
shocks exposes a nation's weak
governance
from there there's no limit to how bad
things can get
for which other country or countries
will the confluence of the pandemic
financial tightening and a drastic
increase in commodity prices soon expose
a weak foundation
when the fed raises interest rates as
it's doing now developing countries have
a harder time paying off their loans
this requires that they choose between
servicing their debt or spending what
little money they have saving lives at
home
some experts are pointing to pakistan
whose currency is currently in rapid
decline as a possible next domino to
fall
this domino however is nuclear
the war alone is expected to decrease
global gdp growth by one percent this
year
put simply a global pandemic a change in
interest rates and the largest armed
conflict in europe since the cold war
would each by themselves be hugely
significant
but all three at the same time
that's why the u.n calls this a perfect
storm
here you can see the last 15 years of
agriculture commodity and grain prices
while high prices don't guarantee social
unrest they tend to correlate
this for example is the arab spring
this meanwhile is where prices were
before the war in ukraine
this is where they're at now
what for the rich world will be an
inconvenience high gas prices
inefficient supply chains and possibly
even recession will for the developing
world mean the undoing of decades worth
of progress in healthcare education and
general prosperity
now you may be wondering why sri lanka
has been the focus of this video when
this is really a global issue
the reason is simple
what's happening in sri lanka is tragic
visible and all too real which makes it
a useful way of humanizing what are
ultimately numbers on a graph
and that's why i love story blocks
video in my opinion is the most
compelling method of storytelling
many of the clips you saw in this video
including the ones you see on screen now
were sourced from storyblocks collection
of over a million clips we found 28
pages of video from sri lanka alone
what i love about youtube is that it
reduces the barriers to creativity
anyone can tell a compelling story
storyblocks likewise does that for video
clips
most stock video costs 50 75 100
per clip storyblocks cost a fraction of
that and gives you access to unlimited
downloads of its entire collection
i just checked my email and confirmed
that i've been using storyblocks now for
four years i was already recommending it
before they became a sponsor
so whether you're a solo entrepreneur an
aspiring filmmaker youtuber or business
professional storyblocks is the go-to
resource for quick easy to find and high
quality video
click the link on screen now or in the
description and sign up for their
unlimited all access plan today